now this is a story all about how my
life got flipped turned upside down this
is the first thing i've ever done acting
you know so i have zero formal
theatrical training this prime time this
ain't cable
in 1990 et made the first of 17 set
visits with event 21 year old fresh
prince i'm here all day acting silly
evening with people i have fun with
enjoy being around
it can't get any better than this
leading up to the season one premiere
will took e.t on a tour of his new digs
welcome to the fresh prince bel air tour
90. it's a party going on right here
i have a tv show coming out uh-huh and
it's you know my like the fresh prince
fresh meaning squeaky clean is that
fresh like you know fresh and wholesome
like fresh not all fresh like that
this is great i think i'm going to like
bella clearly will was having the time
of his life and would often hype up the
audience
the fresh prince propelled will into
icon status while also turning him into
a bona fide sex symbol you know what i
think what it is with the ladies is my
ears man in a mall
these ears
cause hysteria
[Applause]
the sitcom also launched the careers of
his tv cousins alfonso riviero karen
parsons and tatyana ali who was just 11
at the start of the show look i didn't
want everybody to get so upset how long
would you like to see this show run for
forever
just as long as it can
because it's a great you know i think
it's a great show ultimately the fresh
prince went on air for six seasons and
welcomed a slew of guest stars including
a 19 year old tyra banks in her acting
debut we all thought that she was going
to be like one of them model types you
know tyra is like a home girl i'm sorry
the prince and the king the late legend
milton berle also made a cameo while
showing off his rapping skills to e.t i
like to say right today on e.t
i am glad
to really be with a fellow by the name
of will smith we've had a
lot a lot of people
on on this show oprah it was a lot of
fun you can call me oprah
you got it open
oprah everybody's been on the fresh
press entertainment tonight everybody's
going to be here filming this this is
the last intro that they're going to get
e.t was there for the final taping in
1996 there was not a dry eye in the
house everybody got eye boogies oh man
we're only playing a family but you
really develop
family like relationships you know
tatiana's like a little sister to me you
know it makes me uncomfortable to see
her sitting on her boyfriend's lap and
all you know the banks family patriarch
james avery passed away in 2013. during
the final table read he told us this
show was the highlight of his career
we've been very blessed and i don't know
if
our careers are going to continue we're
going to do other things but this has
been the best experience in terms of a
tv show in terms of people and friends
and
happiness and i've got to stop now
okay
[Music]
you